this course is a computer basics course
for people who are brand new to using
computers
it's also great for people who have some
knowledge but just want to fill in some
gaps there are a variety of topics and
you can use the time codes in the
description to skip right to the topic
you want to learn about this course was
developed by gcf global.org
computers are all around us
from laptop computers to smartphones
to smart watches
they're changing the way that we live
our lives
but have you ever asked yourself what
exactly is a computer
a computer is an electronic device that
manipulates information or data
the computer sees data as ones and zeros
but it knows how to combine them into
much more complex things such as a photo
movie
website
game and much more
computers use a combination of hardware
and software
hardware is any physical part of the
computer which includes the internal
components
and the external parts like the monitor
and keyboard
software is any set of instructions that
tells the hardware what to do such as a
web browser media player or word
processor
when most people say computer they're
talking about a personal computer
this can be a desktop computer
or a laptop
which has basically the same
capabilities but in a more portable
package
personal computers come in a few
different styles
the most common type uses the windows
operating system
max or macintosh computers feature the
mac os operating system while
chromebooks run on chrome os
smartphones and other mobile devices
mostly use the ios or android operating
systems
we'll talk more about operating systems
in a later video
computers come in many other shapes and
sizes
tvs game consoles and even appliances
like refrigerators can have built-in
computers although they may not do
everything a desktop or laptop can
there is another type of computer that
plays an important role in our lives
servers
a server sends information to other
computers on a network in fact every
time you use the internet web servers
deliver the web pages that you want to
see to your computer
servers are also used in many offices to
store and share files
as you can see there are many types of
computers out there and each one plays a
part in our modern world
every computer has its own set of
buttons and ports
in this video we're going to talk about
some of the most common ones including
what they're for and how to recognize
them
some buttons are universal like the
power button
depending on the type of computer you
have it may be on the front
on the back behind the screen
or even on the inside when you open the
lid
the power socket is where you'll connect
the power cord
if you have a laptop you'll have a
charging port instead
[Music]
most computers provide more than one usb
port so you can plug in any device you
might need
keyboards printers and usb drives are
all common examples
some computers even have usb-c ports
which can be used for many different
things not just plugging in devices
laptops for instance often use the
format for the charging port
if you have a desktop you'll use the
monitor port to connect the monitor
there are quite a few types of monitor
connections ranging from hdmi to the
usbc style we just mentioned
if you have a laptop you can connect a
separate monitor as long as you have the
right equipment
just look for the display port and plug
in the appropriate
cable the ethernet port lets you connect
to the internet if you're not using
wi-fi
all you need is an ethernet cable which
you can then connect to your modem or
router
if your computer has an audio jack you
can use it to plug in wired headphones
or speakers
you may or may not have a disk drive
depending on how old your computer is
and who makes it
the disk drive can be used to insert a
cd a dvd or a blu-ray disc
if you have ports that look like this
they're for older peripherals like mice
keyboards and printers
newer versions of these devices usually
connect via usb
or wirelessly
that covers the basics of buttons and
ports
of course every computer is different
and technology is always changing to
find out what options you have take a
closer look at your computer
there are many different types of
computers but they all use similar parts
to operate
in this video we're going to show you
what these parts are and what they're
used for
starting with a standard desktop model
the computer case holds the main
components of the computer
this is where the actual processing
happens
today most cases are what we call tower
cases which means they stand up
vertically but they can also come in
other shapes and sizes
to view things on your computer
you'll need a monitor
the monitor uses the video processor
inside your computer case to display
images
text and other content
most monitors have an lcd or led display
both of which are very thin so they
don't take up much space
all-in-one models are even more compact
since they combine the monitor and the
computer case into a single unit
to interact with your computer you'll
need a keyboard and a mouse
keyboards come in many different styles
including wireless and ergonomic
the mouse is used to control the mouse
pointer on the screen
so you can click and interact with your
computer
most mice detect movement using an
optical sensor on the bottom
underneath you'll find a small
electronic eye
laptops combine all of these things into
one
that includes the components that are
normally inside the computer case
plus a built-in screen
keyboard and touchpad
the touchpad is a small touch sensitive
area that takes the place of a
traditional mouse
it lets you control the mouse pointer
using a drawing motion with your finger
laptops offer the best of both worlds
when it comes to portability
you can use them on the go
thanks to the built-in battery or
you can connect a separate monitor
keyboard and mouse
effectively turning your laptop into a
desktop
so those are the basic parts of any
computer setup as you can see each part
plays an important role
which you'll come to understand as you
spend more and more time with your
computer
you may already know that there are many
important parts inside a computer
but what exactly do they do
let's take a look inside and learn about
the various components that make a
computer work
whether it's a desktop computer or a
laptop every computer has a large
circuit board called a motherboard
this contains some of the most important
parts of the computer such as the cpu
also known as the central processing
unit or processor
the cpu can be considered the brain of
the computer because it processes
information and carries out commands
since it tends to get hot it's covered
by a piece of metal called a heat sink
which draws heat away from the processor
the motherboard also contains the
computer's ram or random access memory
this is the short term memory that the
computer uses whenever it's performing
calculations however you cannot store
your files there because the ram is
cleared when you shut off the computer
the hard drive provides long-term
storage keeping all of the computers
data even when it's turned off
many hard drives use a magnetic platter
to store data
but many newer computers have solid
state drives which are faster and more
durable but also more expensive
on many desktop computers the
motherboard has expansion slots that
allow you to upgrade by adding expansion
cards
you can add a video card to get better
graphics performance or you can add a
wireless card to connect to your
wireless home network
most laptops however don't have
expansion slots
of course the computer's components need
electricity to run the power supply unit
is designed to take power from the wall
outlet and send it to all of the
different components that need power
laptops also contain a built-in battery
that lets you use them anywhere
a computer is a pretty complex machine
but now that you've seen what goes on
inside it should be a little less
mysterious
[Music]
if you're thinking of buying a computer
you may have wondered is a laptop right
for me depending on how you plan to use
it the answer may be yes
in this video we'll look at some of the
ways that a laptop is different from a
desktop to help you decide
the biggest difference is portability
laptops have to be small and light so
that you can pick them up and take them
with you
since all of the basic parts are built
in setting up a laptop is as easy as
opening it
the downside is that the monitor is
usually smaller than a desktop monitor
so you'll have less screen space
another important difference is that
laptops use a battery
the battery can provide power to the
laptop when you're on the go and it will
recharge whenever it's plugged in
an added benefit of having a battery is
if the power goes out the battery can
work as a backup power source
instead of a mouse laptops usually have
a built-in touchpad also known as a
you can control the pointer on the
screen by using a drawing motion with
your finger
if you haven't used a touchpad before
the experience is a little bit different
from using a mouse and it may take a
while to get used to
if you're buying a desktop computer you
can mix and match almost any monitor
keyboard and mouse that you want with a
laptop you won't have quite as much
freedom since everything is built in
however if you want to have the best of
both worlds you can use your laptop's
ports to connect a separate monitor
keyboard and mouse basically turning
your laptop into a desktop
and of course whenever you want to you
can simply disconnect everything and
take your laptop with you
as you can see there are some important
differences between laptops and desktops
so depending on your preferences you can
decide which one best suits your needs
did you know that you and your computer
speak different languages
it doesn't speak spanish
or swedish
or chinese
it speaks in ones and zeros
you can't communicate directly with your
computer but that's where your operating
system comes in
the operating system or os
is the program that lets you interact
with your computer
together the operating system and
computer hardware form a complete system
that determines what your computer can
do
there are many different operating
systems
two of the most common ones are
microsoft windows and mac os
windows comes pre-loaded on most
personal computers
while mac os runs on all new macs
operating systems aren't just for
desktop and laptop computers
mobile devices run mobile operating
systems like apple ios or google android
which are designed for interactions with
smaller touch screens
before downloading a new program or
application be aware that it may not be
available for your operating system
some applications work on all devices
while others only work on certain ones
so get to know your operating system to
see how it works and what it can do
if you woke up this morning thanks to
the alarm on your smartphone
or if you like watching videos or
playing games on your tablet
you're using applications also known as
apps
an app is a software program that lets
you do things for lack of a better word
you'll find apps on all of your devices
including smartphones tablets and
computers
some apps help you complete tasks
while others are just for fun
here are some examples of ways you can
use apps
mobile apps are apps that run on your
smartphone or tablet
they can make many things in life more
convenient
for instance if you're looking for a
place to buy coffee an app like google
maps can determine your current location
and then recommend nearby coffee shops
apps aren't just for mobile devices
though
the programs and applications on your
computer can also be considered apps
if you've ever used microsoft word to
create a document
or a web browser to visit a website or
check your email guess what you've used
an app
some apps come already installed but you
can easily download or buy more online
apps are about communication
productivity
entertainment
and more
with so many possibilities you're sure
to find several apps that are perfect
for the things you do
[Music]
are you having trouble putting your
computer together
are you feeling overwhelmed
don't worry
take a deep breath
we're going to show you step by step how
to set up a desktop computer
first unpack everything from the box and
remove any plastic covering or
protective tape
think about where you want your
workspace to go
and how you want to arrange the
different components before you start
plugging things in
next let's connect the monitor
if you have an all-in-one computer where
everything is built in for example an
imac you can skip this step
otherwise locate your monitor cable
newer monitors often use hdmi or usbc
connections
while older monitors may use vga dvi or
another type of connection it just
depends
now find the monitor port on the back of
your computer case and plug the cable in
most cables are designed to fit a
certain way so if it's not working don't
force it
when you're done connect the other end
to your monitor
now it's time to plug in your keyboard
and mouse
if they're wired they most likely have a
usb connector so you can use any of the
ports you see here
you could also plug your mouse into the
usb port on your keyboard if it has one
if you have a wireless mouse or keyboard
it's going to work a little differently
some wireless devices connect using
technology that's built into your
computer
while others need an adapter
you'll also need to pair the device with
your computer before you can use it you
may want to read the instructions that
came with your wireless device to learn
more about pairing
at this point you can plug in your
speakers or headphones
if it uses a typical audio plug
look for the green audio port on the
front or back of your computer case
however
some speakers headphones and microphones
use usb connectors
finally it's time to connect the power
supply cables and plug the computer in
you should have two cables
one goes with your monitor
and the other plugs into the back of
your computer case
now plug both cables into a power outlet
we recommend using a surge protector to
keep your equipment safe in the event of
a power surge
when you're ready plug the surge
protector into a regular outlet
if it has a power switch you may need to
switch it on
that's all there is to it
now take a minute to make sure you're
happy with your workspace
[Music]
then
turn your computer on
there are lots of reasons to set up a
home internet connection for example
you'll have access to email news
shopping tv shows and much more
and once you have a working internet
connection you can create a wireless
home network which will let your whole
family connect their computers
smartphones and other internet ready
devices
let's look at a few different types of
internet connections that you can have
dial-up connects to your phone line
it's usually much slower than other
types of internet connections but in
some areas it may be the only option
available
generally dsl and cable are better
options
dsl plugs into your phone line and cable
uses your cable tv connection
these are both known as broadband
internet connections because they offer
much faster speeds than dial up
this makes it easier to watch videos
play games or browse the web
[Music]
fiber is the fastest type of broadband
currently available
using fiber optic cables it can provide
speeds that exceed even dsl or cable
however it may not be available where
you live
and it tends to be more expensive
cellular is sold under a few different
names including 4g
lte
and 5g
they're types of wireless internet
connections often used by smartphones
but you can also get these types of
connections for your home
depending on where you live
a cellular connection may be a good
broadband alternative
[Music]
no matter what kind of internet service
you choose you'll need to purchase it
from an internet service provider
or isp
chances are you can buy internet service
from your phone or cable company
or you may want to shop around for a
better price
your isp will guide you through the
entire process of connecting to the
internet they will usually need to send
a technician to your home to turn on
your connection
your isp may also give you a modem and
set it up for you
but if you prefer you can buy a modem
from a computer store and use the
included instructions to set it up
yourself
these instructions will vary but the
basic idea is that you'll connect the
modem to your phone jack or cable tv
connection
and then connect your computer to the
modem using an ethernet cable
once you have everything set up you can
open your web browser and begin using
the internet
if you want to connect several devices
to the internet you can create a
wireless home network also known as a
wi-fi network
to do this you'll need a wireless router
which takes the internet connection from
your modem
and broadcasts it throughout your home
your modem may already have a wireless
router built in so you may not need to
buy one
to set up your wireless connection
follow the instructions included with
your router
you'll need to choose a network name
also known as an ssid
also for security you should turn on
wpa2 or wpa3 encryption depending on
what your router supports
then make sure you choose a strong
password
after you've set up your wireless
network go into each device's wi-fi or
network settings select your network
name and type your password
if any of your devices are not wireless
ready you can simply plug them into your
router with an ethernet cable or you can
purchase a wireless card
setting up an internet connection and
wi-fi network takes a little bit of work
but once you get it set up your family
will be able to use the internet without
being limited to one computer
[Music]
so you're at your computer working on
some important files
suddenly a meteorite burst through the
window and flattens the computer
but as you stare into the crater you
smile and think
at least my photos music and important
documents are stored online in the cloud
when something is stored in the cloud
that means it's saved on internet
servers instead of on your computer
it's like having an extra hard drive you
can access anytime you're connected to
the internet
you can access your files anywhere by
using cloud-based apps
some run inside your computer's web
browser these are called web apps
and some of them can also be installed
on your mobile device
for instance google docs is a
cloud-based app that you may already use
it's free and it allows you to view
create and edit many types of projects
you can access google docs from almost
any device with an internet connection
since you only need a connected device
to access the cloud you can take your
files wherever you like
you can take a photo on your smartphone
and upload it to a cloud-based photo
storage service like google photos or
dropbox
then you can access that photo on any of
your other devices like your computer or
tv
you can even work on a document when
you're far away from your desk and share
it with anyone you want
instantly
storing files in the cloud is a great
way to protect them from accidents
viruses and more
you can use cloud-based storage services
like i-drive or back blaze to back up
the contents of your computer
these services run continually and back
up automatically
this way you will always have the most
recent versions of your files stored in
secure online servers
if something bad happens to your device
you can easily transfer your backup
files from the cloud to another device
whether you're backing up photos and
music that you love
or using a file on the go the cloud has
a lot to offer plus when your files are
stored in the cloud you won't need to
worry about losing them to a computer
malfunction
or a rogue meteorite
it's important to keep your computer
clean not only because it looks nice but
also because things like dust and dirt
can affect your computer's performance
but there's a right way and a wrong way
to do it here's the right way to clean
your computer case monitor mouse and
keyboard
first always turn off or unplug the item
before you clean it just to be safe if
it has a ps2 connector like this make
sure the computer is shut down both when
you unplug the cable and when you plug
it back in
to clean your keyboard turn it upside
down and gently shake it to remove any
dust dirt or crumbs it's not uncommon
for stuff to get stuck inside which can
affect the way your keyboard works you
can also use a can of compressed air to
really get between the keys
to clean the surface use a cotton cloth
or paper towel that's moistened with
rubbing alcohol never actually pour
alcohol or any other liquid on your
keyboard
if you spill something by accident don't
panic shut your computer down
immediately then disconnect the keyboard
and turn it upside down so the liquid
can drain
if the liquid is sticky you can rinse
your keyboard under running water just
like this turn to the side then let it
drain upside down for two days before
reconnecting it it may not be repairable
at this point but it's worth a try the
best way to avoid this is to keep drinks
away from the computer area altogether
next take a look at your mouse if you
have an optical mouse good news these
don't require much cleaning at all
because they don't have any moving parts
just keep an eye on the light emitter
underneath if something gets stuck here
even a piece of dust it can keep your
mouse from working
smoothly to clean a mechanical mouse
again make sure it's unplugged then
remove the tracking ball by turning the
ring counterclockwise it should pop
right out
use a cotton cloth or paper towel to
wipe it with a little rubbing alcohol
you can wipe the inside of the mouse too
make sure all the parts are dry before
you put them back together
[Music]
here's an easy tip you can give your
mouse a quick cleaning by rubbing it
back and forth on a clean white sheet of
paper sometimes this is enough to remove
the dust and dirt that can get stuck
underneath
your monitor is going to be even easier
to clean but there are a few things to
keep in mind
never spray the screen directly with
water cleaner or any other kind of
liquid it can leak into the monitor and
damage the components inside
never use glass cleaner like windex this
can damage your screen if it has an
anti-glare coating the safest method is
to unplug the monitor then wipe it with
a soft cloth moistened with water
[Music]
you should also give some thought to
cleaning other parts of your workspace
like the back of your monitor and your
computer case these areas can get pretty
dusty if you're not careful
a lint-free cloth sometimes called a
microfiber cloth is great for wiping the
casings if you see a lot of buildup in
the ventilation pans you can use a can
of compressed air to clean them out
never use furniture cleaner or strong
solvents on any of these surfaces
instead take your cloth or even a paper
towel and spray it with glass cleaner
now wipe the case in monitor housing but
not the monitor screen in a downward
motion
you can make your own solution using
ammonia diluted with water the milder
the
better one more thing you can do to make
sure your computer stays physically
healthy is to watch the airflow around
the case that means no books no stacks
of paper nothing that might block the
fans in the back which are designed to
keep your computer from overheating
in fact if you have a desk with a
compartment for the case you may want to
position the case a little towards the
front or leave the compartment open if
it has a door
both of these steps will help your
computer stay cool
[Music]
looks good to me
just remember to clean your equipment
regularly the right way and your
computer is sure to stay healthy for
years to come
[Music]
we rely on our computers for many
different things
we trust them to keep our information
safe including our files and personal
data
that's why it's important to protect
your computer and do your best to keep
it running smoothly
here are some tips that can help
one of the biggest threats to computer
safety is malware
malware is any type of software that's
designed to damage your computer or gain
unauthorized access to your personal
info
this can include viruses
spyware trojan horses and other
malicious software
windows computers macs and even
chromebooks can get malware
to protect your computer you should use
an anti-virus program
like kaspersky norton or the built-in
windows defender
this helps prevent viruses from being
installed and also lets you scan your
computer and remove any viruses that are
found
keep in mind no anti-virus program is
perfect
to stay safe you should still avoid
suspicious looking ads or downloads
run regular updates to your antivirus
program
and also run updates to your operating
system
to keep your computer running smoothly
the latest version of windows offers a
couple useful features including storage
sense and defragment and optimized
drives
you can access both of these in settings
or you can find them using the search
bar
when you turn it on storage sense helps
you free up space on your hard drive by
scanning for temporary files and other
files that can be deleted
once on it will run automatically in the
background
older versions of windows offer a
similar feature called disk cleanup
[Music]
defragment and optimize drives
rearranges the data on your hard drive
to help your computer run faster and
more efficiently
it should be running automatically on a
weekly basis but you can easily check or
change the schedule anytime
if something bad does happen to your
computer you could lose all of your
important files
to prevent this
you should back up your computer
regularly
one option is to buy an external hard
drive and copy your files to it
to make this process even easier you can
use software like windows backup or time
machine if you're using a mac
of course
if something happens to your computer
and your backup drive you'll still lose
all of your files
for more security you can use an online
backup service like idrive or carbonite
you may have to pay a monthly fee to use
these services but the advantage is that
your files will stay safe in the cloud
no matter what happens to your computer
following these tips can help you
protect your computer and keep your
information safe
you can rest easy knowing that all of
your files will be there when you need
them
the staring at the computer for hours
make you feel tired
do you suffer from frequent aches and
pains
looks like you could use some help with
ergonomics
ergonomics is a big subject but
basically it's about you and the things
that you can do to make your workspace
more comfortable
as strange as it sounds sitting at a
desk all day is actually very hard on
your body
but if you arrange your workspace with
ergonomics in mind you can avoid things
like eye strain and neck and back pain
here are some tips to help you stay safe
comfortable
and productive all day
long keyboard position is important when
you're typing your wrist should be
straight and relaxed to avoid any strain
if you do start to feel any wrist pain
you might want to look into certain
products that can give you extra support
for example an ergonomic keyboard
next raise and lower your chair so that
your wrists are in the correct position
if your feet no longer reach the floor
you can find a foot rest when you're in
your chair you should be sitting in a
natural comfortable position
try to avoid hunching or sitting too
straight
many office chairs are adjustable and
designed to give you extra support
in places where you need it like the
lower back
take the time to learn how your chair
works
your monitor should be a comfortable
distance away from your eyes
somewhere between 20 to 40 inches or
about an arm's length
the top of the screen should be about
eye level but this may vary depending on
the size of the monitor
if you are working from a laptop
consider purchasing an external mouse
and keyboard
that way you can still place your screen
at the proper distance and height while
still being able to type comfortably
adjust the screen brightness on your
monitor so that it matches your
surroundings
if you're looking at your screen and it
feels like you're looking into a bright
light it's too bright
if it looks dark and murky it's too dim
some monitors also allow you to change
the color so that the screen emits less
blue light
this feature might be called night mode
or night shift and some people find that
it greatly reduces eye strain
another way to avoid strain of fatigue
is to take frequent breaks
for example look away from your monitor
every once in a while
20 20 20 is a good rule to follow
every 20 minutes focus your eyes on an
object 20 feet away for 20 seconds
you can even download apps that'll
remind you when it's time to take a
break
it's also important to get up and move
every hour or so
walk around have a snack
whatever it takes to avoid sitting in
the same position for too long
even if you work at a standing desk it's
still important to move every now and
then
clutter is another common problem and it
can lead to strainer injury if you're
not careful
in some cases like loose power cords it
can even be a tripping hazard
if you have paperwork or supplies that
can be put away
it's best to store them somewhere else
instead of leaving them on your desk
let's review
sitting at a desk all day is
surprisingly hard work
but a little attention to ergonomics
will help you stay safe
comfortable
and productive all day long
while you're using the internet you may
be picking up spyware downloading
malware or using fraudulent sites
without even knowing it
but don't worry your browser does a
number of things to help make sure you
avoid running into malicious websites
and there are also some precautions you
can take to stay safe
something as simple as double checking
domain names can save you from
accidentally visiting a site with unsafe
content
malicious sites often use deceptive web
addresses to trick users into believing
they are on a legitimate site
many web browsers will highlight the
domain when you're typing in a site's
web address
in this case it's just a darker font
than the rest of the web address
being able to clearly read the domain
name makes it easier to double check and
make sure it's correct
this will help make sure you're going to
the real trusted site and not a phony
site with a similar web address
and if you are about to access a site
that contains malware or other malicious
content many web browsers will show you
a warning
some websites will display this padlock
image or a similar image
when you see this you know that that
site has added additional layers of
protection by making sure your
connection to the site is secure so
third parties can't see your personal
information
this is most commonly seen on certain
types of sites like banking sites
you won't see this on all websites and
that's okay not all sites need the extra
security
finally another easy way to make sure
your browser is providing as much
protection for you as possible is by
making sure you have the most recent
version of your browser
your browser will usually notify you
when it has a new version or if there's
an update available but if you think
you've missed or ignored updates you can
manually check for updates
in chrome click the menu button
then select about google chrome
by practicing just a few simple safety
measures you can browse the internet
more safely
the internet has become an essential
tool for communicating which is partly
why it has also become a popular target
among scammers and cyber criminals
in order to safeguard yourself from
email scams harmful software or identity
theft it's essential that you understand
the ways you might be at risk
in this video we'll go over the basics
of identifying and avoiding potentially
harmful content on the internet
the first line of defense begins with
your email inbox
you've probably heard the term spam
before in reference to junk email
spammers can send an email to thousands
of people at the same time and they can
do so anonymously making anti-spam laws
hard to enforce so it's important to be
cautious when it comes to opening emails
fortunately though many email services
now provide customizable features to
help you protect your inbox
for example the ability to turn off
email images
spam contains images that senders can
track
when you open the email the images load
and the spammer will be able to tell if
your email works possibly resulting in
more spam
if you're using gmail like i am you can
turn off email images by clicking the
gear icon
and then selecting settings from the
drop down menu
choose ask before displaying external
images
then click save
now if i get an email with images gmail
will ask if i want the images to be
displayed
most email services also check to see if
incoming messages are spam
if it finds spam it will store the mail
in a spam folder so you don't
accidentally open it when you're
checking your email
spam blocking systems aren't perfect
though and there may be times when
legitimate emails end up in your spam
folder so it's a good idea to regularly
check and make sure you aren't missing
important emails
to check your spam folder in gmail click
more in the left pane
then select spam
and here you can see all the emails that
have ended up in your spam folder
many email services have a feature you
can use to mark emails as spam
in gmail i can just select the email
and then click this button to mark it as
spam
this helps your email provider to filter
out these types of messages in the
future
some spam emails are simply annoying
advertisements
others will claim to be contacting you
about something important when what
they're really trying to do is steal
your personal information
this is known as phishing it's a type of
scam in which an email pretends to be
from a bank or another trusted source in
order to trick you into handing over
your personal information by asking you
to complete some sort of action
they may want you to re-enter a password
verify or update sensitive information
like phone numbers addresses or credit
card numbers and they almost always tell
you to do so by following links they
provide
it's a good idea to avoid clicking links
and emails
instead of clicking the link retype the
url into your browser's address bar to
ensure that you go to the correct
website
for example here's an email that looks
like it's from bank of america
saying that some personal information
has been changed and asking me to verify
the changes by following a few links
it looks real enough at first glance but
it's surprisingly easy for scammers to
create deceiving details such as these
remember phishing emails won't always
look like they're fishing the whole
purpose is to look like they're from
your bank credit card or another trusted
company
think of it this way
if someone came to your house saying
they worked for your bank and they
needed your social security number to
verify that you're the account holder
would you give it to them
chances are you wouldn't give out that
information look at emails the same way
just because an email says it's from a
familiar company doesn't mean it really
is
spam scams and phishing schemes will
keep evolving just as the technology to
stop them does
but if you know what to look for and
what to avoid you can keep your inbox
that much safer
suppose you're shopping online for shoes
then you decide to check a health site
and you see an ad for shoes
you switch over to youtube to watch a
hilarious kitten video but first you
have to watch a shoe ad
later you open the facebook app on your
phone and guess what sponsored post
about a shoe sale
how do all of these sites know that
you're shopping for shoes
well websites use various methods to
track your browsing habits
each site may only gather a little bit
of information but together it forms a
sort of digital profile that advertisers
can use to learn all kinds of things
about you
an advertiser can plant a small file on
your computer called a tracking cookie
which they can use to identify you the
next time you visit one of the sites
they advertise on
they can also get a pretty good idea of
which devices you use based on your
social media and email accounts or by
using a technique called probabilistic
matching which makes educated guesses
about which devices belong to the same
person
so one way or another all of your
devices are connected to you and that
means companies can send you targeted
ads no matter which device you're using
this does raise some privacy concerns
since the information is collected
without your knowledge and there is a
fear of how this information could
possibly be used
for instance
could an insurance company deny coverage
based on a person's browsing history
you can take steps to limit the amount
of data collected such as blocking
tracking cookies in your browser
settings but with the current
sophistication of tracking they're
pretty easy to get around
however there are potential upsides to
all this data being collected
it allows sites to recommend articles
and videos based on your interests and
help search engines more quickly find
the results you're looking for
as the technology continues to advance
sites will find new ways to tailor their
content to better meet your needs
it's hard to say exactly where this will
lead but for better or worse digital
tracking is part of the modern online
reality
if you're just getting started with
windows learning how to navigate the
interface is a great place to start
let's take a look at the desktop which
is the screen you see here
it includes a desktop background also
known as your wallpaper
and the taskbar at the bottom of the
screen
the taskbar is where you'll find
shortcuts to some of the applications on
your computer as well as the start
button in most versions of windows you
can click the start button to see a list
of applications files and settings
but if you're using windows 8 you can
click the start button to return to the
start screen
the taskbar is also where you'll find
file explorer which allows you to view
and open files and folders
for now i'm going to close the window by
clicking the x
let's check out more features on the
desktop instead
the desktop is the main workspace for
your computer
to open a program file or folder just
double-click the icon
each time you want to open something it
will appear in a new window
you have the ability to move windows by
clicking and dragging the top of the
window
when you're done just release the mouse
if you have more than one window open at
a time you can quickly switch between
them by clicking the icon for that
window on the taskbar
almost all windows allow you to maximize
the window so that it fills the entire
screen
just click the button here
click the button again to return the
window to its original size
when you're finished closing the window
is easy just click the x
that covers the basics now that you know
your way around windows you can start
taking advantage of everything it has to
offer
if you are just getting started with os
10 learning how to navigate the
interface is a great place to start
first we're going to take a look around
at the desktop which is the screen you
see here
it includes a desktop background also
known as your wallpaper the menu bar at
the top
and the dock at the bottom
the dock is where you'll find shortcuts
to some of the folders and applications
on your computer for example itunes
safari and finder
to open any of the items on your dock
just click the icon
there are actually several different
ways that you can navigate to files
folders and apps in os 10.
the finder feature is one of them we'll
talk more about how to use the finder
later though for now i'm going to close
the window by clicking the red button in
the upper left corner
let's check out launchpad instead which
you can also find on your dock
as you can see launchpad gives you
access to all of your applications at
once making it easier to find and access
the programs on your computer
to open a program click the one you want
exiting applications is just as easy
let's zoom in on the menu bar so you can
see how it works
to exit an application click the name of
the app in the upper left corner
then choose quit from the menu
also on the menu bar is the apple icon
this gives you access to your system
preferences
recent files folders apps and much more
you'll also use the apple icon whenever
you want to restart or shut down your
computer
on the right side of the menu bar you'll
find an icon that looks like a
magnifying glass
this opens a feature called spotlight
which you can use to search the contents
of your computer if you're having
trouble finding something
just type what you're looking for for
example a file or an app and you'll get
a list of search results
the last icon on the menu bar opens the
notification center which has been
included in each version of os 10 since
mountain lion
here you can keep track of the alerts
you receive for different applications
including events on your calendar
reminders and more
the notification center can be
customized to show as few or as many
alerts as you want
the desktop itself is one more place
where you can store files folders and
even shortcuts for easy access this time
however to open an item you'll need to
double-click your mouse
some apps have a full screen mode that
you can activate by clicking the double
arrow in the upper right corner
this causes the window to expand so you
can focus on the application without any
other distractions
to return to normal view press control
command f on your keyboard
not all apps support this feature but
it's available in several of the apps
that come pre-installed on your computer
the last thing i'd like to talk about is
using your mouse in os 10 specifically a
feature called natural scrolling
you can learn more about how it works by
going to system preferences
then choosing mouse or trackpad
depending on what you have in this case
we'll choose mouse
as you can see from the demo natural
scrolling is basically the reverse of
traditional scrolling
it's almost like you're pushing the
content up and down on the page this may
seem awkward at first but it's actually
how many touch screen devices work
natural scrolling is the default setting
but you can always disable it by
checking the box here
i recommend trying it both ways to see
which one you prefer
while you're in this window you can also
take a look at multi-touch gestures
for example here's one that lets you go
back and forth between pages using a
simple swipe
os 10 supports many different types of
gestures including pinches taps and
double taps depending on what your mouse
or trackpad is capable of
each gesture performs a specific task
to learn more i recommend visiting this
resource again once you become more
familiar with os10
that covers the basics
now that you know your way around you
can start using os 10 and taking
advantage of everything it has to offer
a web browser is a tool you use to
access the internet
in order to make the most out of the
internet it's important to understand
the basics of using a web browser there
are many different web browsers
including chrome safari firefox and
internet explorer
all of them allow you to view websites
but they each have a different look and
feel so picking one will depend mostly
on your personal preference right now
i'm using chrome
when you open your browser at the top of
the window you'll see the address bar
this is where you'll type the web
address of the page that you want to
visit
if you've been to a website before your
browser may suggest it or even
automatically complete the address for
you
if you see the address you're looking
for in the suggestions you can just
click it or press enter when you're done
typing
most of the time you're going to go from
one page to another by clicking on links
to go back to the page you were just on
you can click the back button
to return to the first page click the
forward button
if you see a link that you want to click
but you don't want to navigate away from
the page that you're on you can open the
link in a new tab
just right-click the link
and select open in new tab
this opens the page behind the current
page so it doesn't take you away from
the original site
you can also create a new tab by
clicking here
and then typing in the address or name
of any site you want to visit
to close a tab just click the x
if you're on a website that you know
you'll want to visit again later or a
website that you go to frequently you
can bookmark it
most browsers have a button right next
to the address bar that lets you easily
bookmark any site
once you've bookmarked a page you'll be
able to go to it again
in chrome you'll click the settings
button
select bookmarks
and then select the website you're
looking for from the list
even if you don't bookmark a site
there's still a way to find it again
later your browser keeps track of all
the websites you visit in a feature
called history
all browsers allow you to access your
history in chrome you can access this by
clicking the settings button
you can then click on a site to go to it
and as you may remember from before you
can begin typing in the address bar and
your browser will make suggestions these
suggestions come from your history and
bookmarks
the locations of these buttons and other
options may vary a little depending on
which browser you're using
but you should be able to perform all of
the same actions no matter which browser
you decide to use